Transcription: Dominique Partridge
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Je m’appelle Émilie Riger
et je suis écrivaine.
Impressionnant, hein ?
Des siècles de littérature
nous contemplent.
Pourtant, écrire,
nous savons tous le faire.
Mais si.
Rappelez-vous, toutes ces heures,
penché sur vos cahiers,
Peut-être en tirant la langue
pour apprendre ce savoir-faire :
écrire.
Et aujourd’hui, devenu adulte,
ou presque, qu’écrivons-nous ?
Des listes de courses,
des mémos pour le bureau,
des courriers administratifs,
post-it, rendez-vous dentiste.
De l’utile,
du fonctionnel.
Aimeriez-vous en faire autre chose ?
Devenir écrivant ?
Écrivant, c’est ainsi que s’appellent
les membres de mes ateliers d’écriture.
Pas des écrivains,
pas encore, pour certains,
mais des amoureux des mots,
qui apprivoisent
une autre forme d’écriture.
Ni littérature, ni utile.
Une écriture récréation.
Ce n’est pas le bon mot.
Une écriture re-création.
Le journal intime le plus célèbre :
le journal d’Anne Frank.
Un rempart contre la terreur nazie.
Saviez-vous que la glaciale reine Victoria
avait tenu un journal intime
depuis ses 13 ans
jusqu’à la veille de sa mort ?
141 volumes, plus de 8 millions de mots,
pour décrire dans le détail
chaque émotion quotidienne de cette reine
dont le règne de 64 ans
est resté dans l’histoire
comme un symbole d’austérité.
Étonnant, non ?
Le journal intime
est l’album photo de notre cœur.
Il saisit au vol nos chagrins,
nos tendresses, nos réflexions,
tous ces petits événements
trop minuscules
pour marquer notre mémoire
et qui pourtant
nous construisent jour après jour
et font de nous ce que nous sommes.
Écrire régulièrement,
c’est garder la trace de ce chemin
que l’on fait trop souvent en courant.
Prendre un temps de calme
pour faire le point sur soi.
Nous ne sommes, ni la petite Anne
cachée dans son grenier,
ni la reine du plus grand royaume
de son époque.
Alors, tenir un journal,
n’est-ce pas un peu frivole,
voire nombriliste ?
Pourquoi le faire ?
Pour libérer de la place dans nos têtes.
C’est d’ailleurs pour cela
que l’on dresse sans relâche des listes.
Ce qui est posé sur le papier,
nous n’avons plus à le porter,
nous sommes débarrassés.
Avec un de mes enfants, quand il était
petit et qu’il faisait un cauchemar,
nous avions un jeu : écrire
sur une feuille ce qui l’avait effrayé
et ensuite prendre cette feuille
et la chiffonner, la déchirer, la mordre.
On aurait même pu la brûler.
Emprisonné dans le papier,
un monstre peut être vaincu.
L’acte d’écrire,
est rarement innocent.
Le geste d’écrire,
donner à sa pensée l’intermédiaire
de la main,
nous met en contact avec une part
de nous inaccessible en temps normal.
Il se créé un décalage,
comme un court circuit de la raison,
pour penser autrement.
Écrire devient alors un outil
pour communiquer avec soi-même.
J'en fais régulièrement l'expérience
en atelier d'écriture.
Je lance les écrivants sur un thème,
une histoire.
Ils commencent à écrire,
et tout d’un coup,
l’un d’entre eux fond en larmes.
Pas toujours, je vous rassure.
On s’amuse aussi beaucoup
en atelier d’écriture,
mais quand cela arrive,
c’est que les mots
ont débloqué quelque chose,
révélé une blessure tapie dans l’ombre
que l’on croyait guérie depuis longtemps.
Ces jours-là, l’écrivant ressort
de l’atelier apaisé,
comme soulagé d’un poid qu’il n’avait
même plus conscience de porter.
Moi-même, écrivaine expérimentée,
je me laisse attraper par les mots
comme une débutante.
Je m’immerge dans l’écriture d’un roman.
Je laisse les personnages hanter,
mes jours, mes pensées,
mon corps, mes nuits,
pour mieux les écouter.
Et je réalise en posant le point final
que j’ai écrit sur une partie de ma vie.
Écrire,
c’est rendre un peu de cohérence
au brouhaha incessant du monde,
c’est ranger sa tête et faire le tri
de ses expériences.
Comme on range sa maison
et fait le tri de ses placards.
Savez-vous ce que c’est ?
Une baguette magique.
Elle permet de recréer le monde
tel que l’on voudrait qu’il soit.
Nos journées sont pleines de frustrations,
d'obligations, de contraintes.
Or, celui qui tient le stylo,
l’écrivain, l’écrivant, vous, moi,
quand nous tenons
cette baguette magique,
nous devenons des super-héros,
en nous s’emparant du sésame magique,
“Il était une fois”.
Ou celui-ci encore,
“on dirait que je serais ce que je veux”.
Quand j’écris, je retrouve mon âme
d’enfant, je redeviens maître du jeu.
Si vous saviez le nombre de casse-pieds
que j’ai zigouillé dans mes histoires.
Bon débarras !
Dans une histoire, j’arrive même
à imaginer que mon ado range sa chambre,
c’est vous dire !
Cette toute-puissance,
cette bulle où tout est possible,
est jouissive !
Douglas Kennedy nous le dit ainsi:
« Vous ne pouvez pas contrôler la vie.
Vous ne pouvez pas contrôler les autres.
Mais vous pouvez l’écrire.»
Alors, écrire quoi ? Comment ?
Quel est le point de départ ?
À l’origine d’une histoire,
il y a une question:
pourquoi ?
Pourquoi cette personne
se comporte ainsi ?
Alors, cela n’a aucun sens pour moi.
Pourquoi cette situation
a-t-elle évoluée comme ça,
alors que je voulais tout le contraire ?
Écrire une histoire, c’est simplement
tester des hypothèses
pour répondre à cette question,
ce “pourquoi”.
Qu’importe si l’histoire est imparfaite,
incomplète, surréaliste,
voire même surnaturelle.
Une fois qu'elle est écrite,
notre cerveau y croit.
Avez-vous déjà été ém
à la lecture d’un roman,
ri à la description d’une scène cocasse ?
Les personnages vous ont-ils déjà
touché, ému, agacé, attendri ?
Avez-vous déjà ressenti cette tristesse
en arrivant à la fin d’un livre
que vous aimiez ?
Cette envie de repartir au début
et de recommencer le voyage ?
Alors,
vous voyez bien que c’est réel
pour notre esprit.
Écrire,
c’est recréer la réalité.
En 2018,
Je travaille pour une boutique
de copie et d’impression.
Et régulièrement, entre une mamie
qui exige chaque fois une avalanche
de photocopies couleurs,
des photos de ses chats.
Les photos sont moches,
vraiment, vraiment moches.
Et la mamie, infernale.
À force, je vous avoue, elle me fascine.
Comment peut-elle être aussi odieuse
avec tout le monde
alors qu’elle contient autant
d’amour en elle pour ses chats ?
J'ai écrit mon histoire.
Son chat préféré est tout ce qui lui reste
de son fils unique décédé.
Je ne saurai jamai
si mon histoire est vraie ou pas,
et je ne veux pas le savoir.
L’important est que cette histoire
m’a permis de comprendre
pourquoi ces photos si moches
étaient si importantes pour elle.
Et de faire mon travail autrement.
Avec le temps, elle me rendait même
mon sourire en rentrant dans la boutique.
L’écriture est empathie.
Que faire
de tous ces mots
déposés sur le papier ?
Les partager ?
Pourquoi ce partage est-il
si important pour moi ?
Parce que partager, comme ce soir ici,
est ce qui donne du sens
à ce que nous faisons,
à ce que nous sommes.
C’est aussi la condition
sine qua non de la création.
Nous créons à partir de la création
de ceux qui nous ont précédés.
Même un génie comme Léonard de Vinci
n’aurait pas pu créer en partant de rien.
Les autres nous nourrissent.
Partager nos écrits, c’est rendre
un peu de ce que nous avons reçu.
Et l'écriture est magique.
Elle crée une complicité instantanée
et des liens
avec une force impressionnante
qui me surprend encore
après des années d’expérience.
J’ai vu des coups de cœur amicaux
avoir lieu en atelier d’écriture,
des inconnus qui deviennent amis
à la simple lecture de quelques lignes.
J'ai vécu mes propres coups de cœur.
J'ai une immense gratitude
pour l'écriture.
Elle a fait entrer dans ma vie
l’homme que j’aime
et des personnes absolument fantastiques.
J’ai chaque fois rencontré
la personne que j’attendais
après l’avoir lue.
C'est un merveilleux cadeau.
Pourquoi cette intimité si soudaine ?
Je partage avec vous
le fruit de ma réflexion
après des années d’expérience
en tant qu’écrivaine et que lectrice.
Le choix de nos mots,
la façon de les arranger entre eux,
le rythme de nos phrases...
Quand nous écrivons,
c’est la partie la plus authentique
de nous qui transparaît,
même dans ce que l’on veut cacher.
Celui qui nous lit ne connaîtra pa
nos secrets, bien sûr.
Mais il comprendra à un niveau subliminal
notre identité profonde.
Nos corps communiquent avec des phéromones
dont nous n’avons pas conscience.
J’ai la conviction
que nos esprits et nos cœurs
partagent...
communiquent, échangent
avec cette part de nou
qui cimente nos mots.
J’emprunte les mots de Philippe Besson
pour vous le dire autrement :
« Je t’écris,
parce que t’écrire,
c’est être avec toi. »
Le plus difficile finalement
dans cette histoire d’écriture,
c’est de se sentir légitime pour écrire,
se donner le droit de prendre le stylo,
ignorer cette petite voix qui susurre
qu’on ne sait pas écrire.
Ça n’intéressera personne.
Et si j’allais plutôt passer l’aspirateur
pour faire quelque chose «d’utile» ?
Vous connaissez le nom de
l’inventeur de l’aspirateur ?
Ben moi non plus,
mais nous connaissons Charles Baudelaire
et Les fleurs du mal,
Ernest Hemingway,
Le vieil homme et la mer.
Margaret Atwood, La servante écarlate,
Albert Camus, La peste ou l'Étranger.
George Sand, La Petite Fadette,
et tant d’autres.
Même si nous ne les avons pas lus,
leurs œuvres nous appartiennent.
Nous connaissons leur histoire
leurs personnages.
Ils font partie
de notre identité culturelle.
Vous ne me croyez pas ?
Un séducteur est un…
Don Juan, Molière !
Combien d’entre nous ont eu l’héroïsme,
n’ayons pas peur des mots,
de lire Proust ?
Pourtant, nous connaissons l'histoire
de sa madeleine.
Et celle d’Esmeralda et son bossu,
nés sous la plume de Victor Hugo
dans Notre-Dame de Paris.
Le légendaire nez de Cyrano de Bergerac
créé par Edmond Rostand.
Et notre chouchou à tous,
dans le monde entier,
Le Petit Prince d’Antoine
de Saint-Exupéry,
avec sa rose et son renard
que l’on voudrait tant apprivoiser.
Impressionnants, ces noms
qui traversent les siècles !
Alors, ai-je le droit d’écrire,
si je ne m’appelle pas Émile Zola ?
Qu’en pensez-vous ?
Voulons-nous n’être qu’utile, construire
nos vies sur cette valeur si pragmatique ?
L’utilité, vraiment ?
Nous sommes beaucoup plus que ça.
« Écrire
est une façon d’exister »,
disait Flaubert.
Nous en avons tous le droit.
Ce soir,
prenons ce précieux sésame.
Il était une fois...
Et vous ?
Quelle sera votre histoire ?